i wonder i don't know what what did you
guys think going into trash takes like
what did you think was going to happen
i when you join a podcast i feel like
we've all been on a podcast we all hear
the podcast experience
yeah you know so i i wasn't i wasn't
expecting that exactly but
i wasn't expecting anything different
yeah yeah absolutely i wasn't expecting
anything crazy
i i think the biggest thing is that
obviously none of us expected
for trash taste to be this successful um
because we were i remember when we were
planning this the reason
our studio is so small right now and the
reason we're moving into a new one is
because
we were literally just paying for this
out of pocket and we you know we didn't
know
how successful if this was even going to
make money within the first year
like i remember the [ __ ] ton of our own
money just to be like
we think this can work let's give it a
chance i mean i remember like
i keep saying it on episodes but i
remember still you know during the first
week or two
where god and i wouldn't be like it'd be
nice if we hit 100k
by the end of the year and now you're
approaching this one this is
we're almost at a million this is the
end of the year just [ __ ] nuts
yeah i mean i can't believe we're just
approaching a [ __ ] million
right that's insane i mean i think i
think it's safe to say that we kind of
like underestimated the potential of a
podcast right i mean i remember
before we even started this podcast we
looked at some of the other competition
out there
right and we were just like okay here's
here's a reasonable estimate of where we
might end up
and it turns out we were just like
[ __ ] five like
10 places too lower than what we thought
we were going to
you know where we thought we were going
to be um i guess before we
unveil the last award um
we'd like to say well we'd like to say a
few words if that's cool go ahead
let's fix this open now before oh i'm
sure crack it crack it open now
for now now
we're known for talking [ __ ] a lot but
congratulations if we could get real for
a second
joey i just wanted to say something to
you okay like
before you know you are one of my best
mates before we start this podcast
and now you're not and like
like especially being on this podcast
every week and just sitting next to you
every week and discussing all that all
of our [ __ ]
it [ __ ] like blows my mind how
similar we are sometimes
like it's it's it's [ __ ] insane that
sometimes you say something i have a
thought and i'm just like god damn it
joey
i was gonna say stop being the same
person as me and it's it's gotten
it's gotten so much i think we've just
like kind of assimilated our like new
answers and everything which you can see
by the amount of clips we have of just
me and joey being insane thinking about
like that
you know it's not just what happens when
you sit next to your best mate for like
both took the red pill in yeah yeah
fully assimilated yeah yeah i know and
like i couldn't be happier to
you know be singing across you and
connor i know you were [ __ ] like
nervous as [ __ ] when before starting
this podcast
because i know like compared to me and
joey you're you are
like uh you were like you weren't small
but you're like way less established
than you were than us you know this is
that's interesting it is true
i'm just talking i was very concerned
about it and i know you were concerned
coming into this podcast that people
would just be like who the [ __ ] is this
guy
who's this guy yeah who's this guy he he
does like [ __ ] black butler
fandubs like who the [ __ ] is this guy no
but um
like i i couldn't be more proud of you
as a mate to see how much you've grown
in the last year
because like i i think i think out of
everyone you've like grown
the most absolutely in the past year of
trash taste and you've definitely like
[ __ ] established yourself
and like you know i you know as a mate i
couldn't be [ __ ] proud of you come on
get ready
i'm sure i'm sure you'd hug too and
everybody clapped
and i guess the last thanks i want to
give is
to me lynn yeah
honestly um we wouldn't be here without
mailing honestly
yeah you know me and connor would not be
here in japan
and for sure you did a [ __ ] like i
know you told the story about how you
just
brought us here because it was like a
company competition
for me everyone give a round of applause
to megalin
take a bow melin i have to buy this
outfit
that's why you bought the album actually
you didn't come in a t-shirt be like
yeah i made the boys
yeah and i guess i guess last but last
i guess after melin is obviously you
guys i mean we
have just talked about how we did not
expect the audience that we were gonna
get
and i certainly didn't expect to have an
audience that was like this dedicated
the subreddit is a lot more popular than
i thought it was going to be
yeah the memes are fantastic the fan
art's fantastic the animation
the animations are fantastic you guys
are just fantastic yeah just how
dedicated you guys are to just us
rambling every week for two hours is
just [ __ ] nuts and i think like
biggest thing more than anything it
really gave me personally
a lot of confidence in just me as a
person
yeah like completely separate from my
personality and like
i don't know that's like uh that feels
great right it's like oh i'm getting
validated for just
being me and there's no better feeling
than that so yeah
yeah god it feels it sounds like we're
about to like end the podcast yeah
that's my final episode guys it's nice
man i feel like you know you you ready
you already feel like you've made
friends for life but i really do
i'm very lucky to have you know you guys
i'm very very grateful very grateful
i'm really happy as well